Did Robin make an appearance in "The
Batman" without anybody noticing?
Well, yes…and no. Keep watching to
find out how the Boy Wonder appeared
alongside Robert Pattinson's
Dark Knight in "The Batman"!
After long production delays due to
COVID-19, "The Batman" is finally here.
The latest story told on screen featuring one
of DC Comics' most famous characters is helmed
by director Matt Reeves, previously known for his
work on "Dawn of the Planet of the Apes," "War for
the Planet of the Apes," and "Cloverfield."
After Ben Affleck decided to step away from
playing the Caped Crusader, Reeves stepped
up to tell a new Batman story with Pattinson.
"The Batman" also features a plot with the main
antagonist being The Riddler played by Paul Dano,
a character we haven't seen in live-action since
Cory Michael Smith played the role on "Gotham."
Before that, there was 1995's "Batman Forever"
with Jim Carrey playing a highly charismatic,
obsessive, and very campy version
of the classic Batman villain.
Dano's version is incredibly dark, violent,
and vengeful. Although both "Batman Forever"
and "The Batman" feature The Riddler
as one of their main antagonists,
there are pretty vast and obvious differences
between both films. For one, there is a
massively important character missing from
"The Batman" that was featured in 1995 — Robin.
Although nothing is really ever hinted about
Dick Grayson or Robin during "The Batman,"
an actor who had previously played
one of the Robins in live-action
appeared very early on in the movie, and
you might've missed him in his big scene.
While the opening to "The Batman" starts off
by introducing us to a very demented and creepy
Riddler, it isn't long before moviegoers are
hit with a narration from Robert Pattinson's
Bruce Wayne. It's Halloween night and Gotham City
is celebrating, but as Bruce notes, crime still
runs rampant. Gotham City Police Department
Lt. James Gordon, played by Jeffrey Wright,
lights up the Bat-Signal, and we see common
criminals on the streets start to get scared,
feeling fearful that somewhere nearby,
Batman could be hiding in the shadows.
The film cuts to the subway where
a few face-painted men are huddling
around watching a video they took of
themselves assaulting someone for fun,
although the youngest in the group
seems to be uncomfortable with it.
Without much dialogue, the youngest is told by
the leader of the group to pursue and attack
another person on the subway with them, and
as they do, they're confronted by Batman.
As seen in the first trailer for
the film, Batman beats the leader
and utters an iconic line that plays an
important role throughout the actual film:
"I'm vengeance."
The rest of the group — except for the young kid
— proceed to attack Batman and fail. He and Batman
share a look, where the kid seems simultaneously
relieved that Batman showed up and also amazed
by what he sees — and then he runs off. This
kid happens to be played by actor Jay Lycurgo.
In the credits, the kid is referred to
simply as "Train Gang Young Member" — but
he actually plays a character who's known
as DC Comics' Robin in another project.
If you're a DC fan, you probably saw Jay Lycurgo
playing Tim Drake in Season 3 of "Titans" before
his quick part in "The Batman." The HBO Max show
actually centers around being Robin in general,
as the first season introduces fans
to the original Robin, Dick Grayson,
who's played on the show by Brenton Thwaites.
The series covers his journey to step out from
being under the shadow cast by Batman and
become his own hero — Nightwing. Soon after,
we are introduced to Curran Walters' Jason Todd,
and in Season 3 we are introduced to Tim Drake,
an intelligent young man who figures out
on his own that Nightwing is Dick Grayson,
Robin was (prior to his death) Jason
Todd, and that Bruce Wayne is Batman.
During Season 3, Lycurgo's Tim goes through
quite the transformative experience,
as he is at one point shot by Scarecrow,
played by Vincent Kartheiser, and nearly dies.
During the finale of Season 3, we see that Tim
is accepted by the Titans and leaves with Dick
and most of the team to San Francisco and the
Titans Tower once more. Lycurgo is set to return
as a recurring character in Season 4 of the show,
which has already started production. It's likely
Tim's training from Dick or Bruce might be
a focus in the show's plot moving forward.
It's impossible to know whether we will see
Lycurgo again in possible sequels to "The Batman."
It seems unlikely that the actor would
play two different Robins in two different
live-action universes. Then again, we do
have three different actors set to play
three different big-screen versions of Batman
in the same year, so anything's possible.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.